la inseguridad en el centro del
referendo de Ecuador este domingo el
país fue a las urnas en sus elecciones
regionales un acontecimiento en el que
también decidieronse aprobar o no una
serie de modificaciones a la
Constitución
una votación que llega después de que
Ecuador viviera uno de sus años más
críticos en términos de violencia de
diferentes tipos en 2022 Ecuador
registró unas 4.550 muertes violentas
82,5 más que en 2021 y su registro más
alto desde 1990 así el gobierno de
Guillermo lasso ha promocionado y
alentado a votar a favor de las
modificaciones asegurando que se
encaminarán a revertir dicha situación
la primera pregunta con la que se
encontraron los Ecuatorianos fue está
usted de acuerdo con permitir la
extradición de Ecuatorianos que hayan
cometido delitos relacionados con el
crimen organizado transnacional
según el gobierno la extradición hasta
el momento prohibida por la Carta Magna
del país ayudará a desmantelar las
bandas de crimen organizado y también
tendrá una función disuasiva una
justificación que ha generado críticas
de varios sectores que señalan que no es
suficiente para luchar contra las
inseguridades del país y que hacen falta
medidas profundas contra la pobreza y la
desigualdad al mismo tiempo los
Ecuatorianos votaron sobre la autonomía
de la fiscalía general del estado una
propuesta que ha sido defendida por
lasso quien señala que con mayor
Independencia esta podrá afrontar de
manera más oportuna los casos de
delincuencia en 2022 el gobierno
ecuatoriano optó por decretar el estado
de emergencia en varias regiones del
país debido a un repunte de la violencia
sobre todo en las cárceles
terminando el año como uno de los países
en donde los ciudadanos se sienten más
inseguros de la región según ganó